-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
Well, guys, I have some news
to make people feel
a little better.
And that is the royal family
is just as messed up
as everyone else's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, last night,
Oprah sat down with
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
for a two-hour
prime-time special.
I actually thought
it was a great interview.
Obviously, I love Oprah.
She's the best.
But good on Meghan Markle for
being brave enough to talk about
her own mental-health struggles
and all the stuff
she had to deal with.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, we learned quite a bit
about the rules,
the protocols, the firm.
We even learned that Tyler Perry
took them in
when they came to America
and provided them with security.
Basically, if you missed
the interview,
the royal family
was like, "Goodbye,"
and Tyler Perry was like,
"Heller."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, last night was an intense
and emotional two hours.
My wife, she walked in
and asked why I was crying.
I was like, "The NBA all-star
game is really good this year."
[ Laughter ]
"Steph Curry sank
a Mountain Dew ball."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we learned quite a bit
from the interview,
like what we've been missing
all year wasn't a normal life.
It was Oprah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was a big event,
mainly because they revealed
the baby's gender in California
without burning down
an entire forest.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Last night, 17 million people
watched the special,
which means the biggest shows
on TV this weekend
were all about
powerful women and redheads.
[ Laughter and applause ]
17 million.
The ratings were so big,
ABC just offered the couple
their own weekly show
called "Royal-ish."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, over 17 million viewers
tuned in.
CBS celebrated until they heard
that more than 600 million
watched a TikTok about
feta cheese.
[ Laughter ]
If you thought this interview
was big, tune in next Sunday
when Prince Charles is on "Dr.
Phil" like, "Catch me outside."
[ Laughter ]
"How about that?
Catch me outside?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Oprah's interview was
such a big ratings success,
she's already got another
prime-time special in the works.
Check out this promo I saw.
-Oprah is back with
another prime-time interview
with another powerhouse couple.
-You don't know what
I'm going to ask.
-And it's her most intense...
-What was that conversation?
-...interview...
-Wait, hold up.
-...yet.
-So, are you ready?
[ Laughter ]
-Oprah with
Mr. and Mrs. Potato Head.
-Unbelievable.
Another big moment during
the interview was when Harry was
asked about his dad,
and he casually mentioned this.
-When we were in Canada,
I had three conversations
with my grandmother and two
conversations with my father
before he stopped
taking my calls.
-Even worse,
he'd respond to texts with,
"New mobile, whom is this?"
[ Laughter ]
"New mobile, of whom is this?"
We actually got our hands
on the last phone call
between Harry
and Prince Charles.
It's pretty intense.
Check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That can't be
a real phone call, right?
Where are we getting that?
That can't be real.
-No way.
-Another big revelation was
that Meghan said she and Harry
actually got married three days
before the royal wedding.
Great, now I feel like a fool
for waking up at 5:00 a.m.
to watch two married people
get married.
[ Laughter ]
When she heard about the secret
wedding, the Queen was so upset,
she asked for
her panini maker back.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was
a truly explosive interview
with shocking revelations that
will stick with us for decades,
like this one.
-My first job was when I was 13
at a frozen yogurt shop
called Humphrey Yogart.
[ Laughter ]
-Even weirder,
Harry worked at a sewing shop
called Alfred Stitchcock's.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, let's switch gears
here a little bit.
During a press briefing today,
the director of the CDC
announced new guidelines
for vaccinated Americans.
Watch this.
-If you're fully vaccinated
and you're indoors,
there is no need for masks
or social distancing
if everyone there
is fully vaccinated.
-Oh, man, bingo halls
are about to look like
a Señor Frog's on spring break.
[ Laughter ]
Most Americans are like,
"Great news!"
While Texas is like,
"What the hell's a CDC?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, you can gather with anyone
who is vaccinated,
and more importantly,
you can act like a smug A-hole
around anyone who's not.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell things are getting
better because the head of
the CDC came out and asked
if anyone wanted the rest
of her breath mint.
Like, "Oh, come on, hey."
[ Laughter ]
You're taking it too far now.
"Who wants it? Who wants it?
Huh, huh?"
[ Laughter ]
-Eww!
-That's right.
According to the CDC,
two weeks
after getting vaccinated --
[ Laughter ]
Did you like that?
Did you see what I'm saying,
dude?
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
According to the CDC,
two weeks
after getting vaccinated,
grandparents can hug
their grandchildren.
Or as this grandmother put it,
"Yeah, it might be a bit longer
than that."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone is
talking about this.
Today, Burger King U.K.
announced a new program
that helps female employees who
are pursuing culinary careers,
but they're getting
a lot of criticism
for how they went about it.
They sent a tweet out that said,
"Women belong in the kitchen."
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Anyway, happy International
Women's Day, everyone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm pretty sure one PR person
just flame-broiled their career.
[ Laughter ]
As soon as it happened, 10,000
people broke their fingers
rushing to be
the first one to tweet,
"What a whopper of a mistake."
[ Laughter ]
Man, but what a gaffe
for Burger King U.K.
Overall, just a brutal week
for the British royals.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, in Oklahoma,
there's a reward being offered
for something
pretty interesting.
Listen to this.
-A sizable bounty is now
on a legendary figure.
Bigfoot is now
wanted in Oklahoma
for more than $2 million.
-Nice try, Oklahoma.
You're still not
as crazy as Texas.